peintures de la fête de l'humanité c'est
en direct sur les chaînes parlementaires
chers amis
chers camarades quel bonheur
quel bonheur de se retrouver ici si
nombreux pour faire humanité ensemble
oui l'humanité quel beau nom porteur de
lumière et d'espoir porteur du projet de
réalisation de soi et du projet d'un
monde commun aux femmes et aux hommes un
monde de partage et de justice un manque
de solidarité de générosité et de total
respect il faut remonter loin très loin
pour retrouver une participation si
exceptionnelle à la fête à ses concerts
et à ces débats nous avons été plus de
600 milles à la fête
si le peuple de l'humanité est venu
ainsi en masse c'est parce que toutes et
tous nous recherchons l'unité nous avons
besoin de nous serrer les coudes
nous sommes venus dire avec force que la
vie ne peut plus continuer ainsi le
pouvoir de droite et sarkozy devront
bien tenir compte de ce qui se passe ici
à la fête de l'humanité
mais cela nous oblige cela oblige à
rechercher du neuf à proposer un projet
tout à fait nouveau voilà le grand enjeu
de leurs voiles à l'oeuvre historique à
laquelle nous devons nous atteler toutes
et tous ensemble ici on sort de l'air
nauséabond des petites combines
politiciennes de la tricherie de la
trahison des coups bas de cette
insupportable violences faites aux
femmes et aux hommes
ici c'est l'ère de la fraternité de la
solidarité celui de la diversité de la
richesse culturelle des talents vrai de
la connaissance et des débats celui
aussi de la tolérance et de les coudes
réciproque de l'ouverture sur le monde
et ses causes les plus nobles parmi
lesquelles celle de la paix du
désarmement de l'éradication de la faim
de la misère de l'analphabétisme et des
pandas ni alors que terribles actes
d'asud d'accusation contre ce
capitalisme sauvage
toutes les cinq secondes oui toutes les
cinq secondes un enfant meurt de faim
dans le monde
pourtant les moyens financiers humains
techniques scientifiques existent seule
la volonté politique fait défaut
eh bien il est bien là le scandale ici
c'est l'ère de la paix avec cette
exigence de voir la france se retirer du
bourbier afghan et agir pour que
l'argent des armes servent à améliorer
la vie du peuple et à combattre la
corruption et le trafic de drogue
notre pays n'a pas vocation à s'aligner
sur les états unis
sa réintégration dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan par le militariste
sarkozy est une faute grave qui aura de
lourdes conséquences
la voix de notre pays mais forte que
quand elle est libre l'ère de la fête
c'est cette constante solidarité que
vous nous venons d'avoir à l'égard du
peuple martyr palestinien les
palestiniens en droit un état sans mur
et sans mirador avec jérusalem est comme
capitale
que s'applique enfin les résolutions de
l'organisation des nations unies dans
cette partie du monde
terre de souffrances innommables que
tous les prisonniers politiques
palestiniens soient libérés
immédiatement et sans condition
oui falloir liberté pour marouane
barghouti
oui donné sa maman liberté pour salah
hamouri qu'ils soient libérés
immédiatement et sans conditions par les
autorités israéliennes liberté aussi
pour yann san suu kyi la prix nobel de
la paix infatigable combattant de la
démocratie liberté et démocratie avec
nos frères d'afrique que la mascarade
gabonaise vient nous rappeler avec
partout la misère le pillage des
richesses naturelles par les grands
groupes internationaux et des dynasties
locale au comportement de sangsues la
france à entre la france à rentrer quand
son ministre des affaires étrangères
vient apporter sa caution à ce que
produit de pire le capitalisme là bas
bien différent et l'air respiré ici dans
cette fête
1 ère où le besoin de préservation de
notre planète
l'ambition de développement humain
durable solidaire celle indissociable de
l'émancipation humaine se sont exprimées
avec force
il est temps grand temps de changer
radicalement le système de production de
consommation de distribution de
préserver les ressources naturelles et
la biodiversité
on ne peut pas laisser plus longtemps
le capitalisme surexploités l'homme est
surexploité la nature
au contraire les réponses aux urgences
sociales et aux urgences écologie ne
font qu'une
ici flotte anr où l'on sent que la
politique la recherche de solution
d'intérêt général et de perspective
progressiste est aux antipodes de la fij
en spectacle médiatique dominant coffre
bien trop souvent la politique spectacle
qui pousse tant de nos concitoyens à
s'éloigner de ceux qui devraient
pourtant les concernés au premier chef
l'organisation de leur vie et de la
société éloignement d'un seul profitent
les puissants de ce monde tout ce qui
fait la spécificité de cette fête avec
la mobilisation des équipes du journal
le dévouement sans limite des militants
tout cela échappe durant trois jours aux
valeurs des rapaces de la finance
celle qui broie tout et façon amende de
bruxelles de l'argent roi
c'est déjà assez puissance financière et
industrielle que ce rtains jean jaurès
le fondateur de notre journal jusqu'à y
laisser sa vie
nous sommes fiers vous ne pouvez pas
vous imaginer à quel point de poursuivre
son oeuvre
l'oeuvre du défenseur alassane des
paysans et des ouvriers
le patriote et internationaliste le
militant laïque hepatitis
au quart de ces combats n'a été vains
son action inlassable pour rassembler
unir la gauche sur des bases claires a
permis dans notre pays des avancées des
progrès pour le monde du travail et de
la création
c'est précisément cette spécificité qui
était devenue insupportable aux maîtres
de la finance à vis d'exploitation sans
contrat ni retenue et ils ont trouvé
leur homme
l'homme de la situation pour passer au
karcher acquis sociaux démocratiques et
culturels il s'appelle monsieur sarkozy
ce monarque du royaume de la haute
finance
ce petit tenanciers de l'économie de
casino qui s'est donné pour mission de
modeler la france que dis-je de
déchiqueter la france des lumières de la
révolution française de 36 de la
libération 2,68 et de la gauche entre
lui et nous c'est le jour et la nuit
nous nous sommes les combattants de la
solidarité
lui c'est le petit soldat de la mise en
concurrence de la recherche du profit
maximum pour les membres de sa seule
casse lui il prend l'argent au pot pour
les donner aux riches
nous nous sommes les militants du
pouvoir d'achat pour les familles
populaires et pour l'augmentation du
smic à 1600 euros tout de suite
lui c'est le fabricant de la précarité
de la destruction d'emplois du
démantèlement des services publics et de
la protection sociale
nous nous sommes les militants de la
sécurité du travail de l'emploi de la
création de nouveaux métiers pour faire
reculer la crise écologique
nous nous sommes les défenseurs
inlassable des services publics de la
sécurité sociale et des retraites parce
que nous considérons que le travail et
les formations sont des trois îles et
nani ligne a in alignable et que nous
considérons que l'air l'eau la santé la
retraite le logement l'énergie le
transport la poste l'alimentation et
même l'accès au crédit sont des biens
communs à toute l'humanité dont des
biens publics
et si ce sont des biens publics ils ne
peuvent pas être gérée pour faire de
l'argent mais au contraire pour répondre
aux besoins humains et environnementaux
dans ces conditions ce n'est pas
privatiser qu'il faut faire mais
progresser vers une appropriation
sociale citoyenne et démocratique de ses
biens c'est à dire qu'il faut plus de
service public d'un nouveau type dans le
temps nous aurions dit de nouvelles
nationalisations
il n'y a donc rien de plus urgent pour
les parties les élus de gauche que de se
mettre à la disposition de tous ses
salariés et de toutes ces familles qui
souffrent durement rien de plus urgent
que de résister d'arracher des résultats
d'obtenir l'interdiction des
licenciements boursiers notamment une
augmentation substantielle des salaires
et l'arrêt des privatisations
à commencer par celles de la beauce
mais ça ça c'est tout le contraire de
l'affligeant spectacle offert par le
minable combat des esgaulx la recherche
de combinaisons politiciennes et astuces
pour contourner la question de ce qu'il
faut faire pour que la vie la politique
la france l'europe et le membre soit
plus beau plus solidaire plus juste car
enfin avant nous besoin de demander sa
carte d'identité à ce monsieur bayrou
pour savoir si par hasard il serait de
gauche il a commencé il a commencé par
jusqu'à destin il s'en est pris à
l'école publique il mène campagne pour
une europe encore plus ultra libérale
qui peut croire qu'il a un seul gène de
gauche nous ne sommes pas dû il caresse
une partie de la gauche pour la
convertir à la croix voilà la réalité
mais nous nous laisserons pas faire
quand on est de gauche on se doit
non pas de se perdre de cette mélasse
politicienne mais de combattre pied à
thiais le sarkozy au service de ces
brigands de la finance
quand on est de gauche on se porte
devant des travailleurs des jeunes des
retraités au devant du peuple pour
élaborer avec lui ce projet nouveau de
l'après capitalisme
cette évolution révolutionnaire capelle
ce 21ème siècle comme le disait karl
marx et jean jaurès oui oui post
capitalisme pour signifier d'une part
que le capitalisme a démontré qu'il
était incapable incapable de donner du
travail un toit les moyens de vivre
d'apprendre de se soigner à toutes et à
tous d'autre part pour marquer que les
réponses ne sont écrites nulle part ni
dans le passé ni même dans notre présent
pas plus que dans un rêve aussi généreux
soit il elles sont à inventer ici et
maintenant
toutes et tous ensemble le monarque de
l'elysée qui incarne ce capitalisme dit
maintenant vouloir le moraliser
paraît-il il avait d'ailleurs promis
qu'en travaillant plus on gagnerait plus
et qu'il n'y aurait plus d'impôts
supplémentaires
résultat les chômeurs les jeunes
diplômés ou non sans travail
les précaires n'ont jamais été si
nombreux
alors que de hiva nous obligés désormais
à travailler le dimanche
le smic est bloquée et les fins de mois
sont une hantise pour des millions de
salariés des retraités
depuis les franchises médicales jusqu'à
l'augmentation du forfait hospitalier à
cette fameuse taxe carbone il ne cesse
de pomper dans la poche de celles et
ceux qui n'en n'ont déjà pas beaucoup
d'argent qu'il nous explique ce qu'il y
a de morale quand des individus
disposent chacun de plus d'un milliard
d'euros dans le coffre fort d'un paradis
fiscal
eux ce sont les sans-domicile fiscaux
par comme maintenant de plus en plus de
salariés deviennent malheureusement des
sans domicile fixe
pour et la morale quand les conditions
d'exploitation la souffrance au travail
poussent des salariés de grandes
entreprises au suicide ou quand une
famille des enfants à quelques
kilomètres d'ici sont expulsés manu
militari de leur appartement en pleine
nuit où dorment dans les bois ou mort du
périphérique
qu'y at-il de morale à tout cela voilà
le bilan de ce malaise zélés du capital
c'est révoltant c'est dégoûtant
pendant ce temps là les plus riches
reçoivent chacun chaque année d'échec
écoutez bien équivalent à 30 années de
smic parce qu'ils sont pénitentiaire de
son fameux bouclier fiscal en somme
ensemble ne le lâcheront pas réclamant
un bouclier social
il est vraiment sans le moindre contrôle
mais vous vous n'avez pas accès au
crédit
résultat ces banquiers dégouline
aujourd'hui 2 milliards et on nous fait
croire qu'il n'ya pas d'argent pour les
salaires l'enseignement ou la
modernisation des services publics
mais pour qui nous prend ton ensemble ne
le lâcheront pas
unissons nous pour obtenir un pôle
public des bancs des nationalisations de
banques pour obtenir un crédit utile
pour l'emploi les salaires les cols des
hôpitaux pour les artisans et pour les
petites et moyennes entreprises
et et n'hésitons pas à clouer le bec à
ces requins de la finance qui n'assure
leur tas d'or dans leur coffre fort qui
ne cesse de crier comme au temps de
molière ma cassette nos bonus nous deux
options ou parachutes dorés nos
retraites chapeaux eh bien nous nous
disons intérêt général
salaires emploi écoles recherche
c'est en faisant comme cela on sortira
de la crise est l'hôte de l'élysée qui
se déguise désormais de temps en temps
un petit policiers avaient promis une
ère de sécurité
n'hésitant pas à stigmatiser les jeunes
et les étrangers de nos quartiers
populaires ce qui semble d'ailleurs
avoir beaucoup plus aux électeurs du
front national
résultat les atteintes aux personnes les
agressions sont en forte hausse
mais qu'on se rassure le chef de l'état
et son fidèle ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur hortefeux très sélect
aujourd'hui vont s'en occuper
d'ailleurs quand on entend beaucoup
parler de sécurité à la télévision c'est
un signe incontestable qu'on s'approche
d'une élection il avait promis un
quinquennat écologique ce qu'ils avaient
compris que l'heure était enfin venu de
développer des transports en commun
accessible confortable et sûr de
développer le transport par fret
ferroviaire de construire de nouveaux
bâtiments de nouveaux moteurs bref de
vivre autrement ont été trompés tous
ceux là ont eu la très mauvaise surprise
de voir apparaître ce nouvel impôt un
impôt on dit qu'il y faire mais
savez-vous en le regardant bien on voit
qu'il a la couleur d'une vieille carte
grise défraîchi anna peau qui n'a que
pour seule justification que de faire
payer par le peuple
une partie de la taxe professionnelle
dont seront exonérés les entreprises
cette taxe cette taxe qui permet jusque
là notamment aux communes jeudi ça
devant mon avis en brèche à celle de
faire face à leurs responsabilités à
l'égard des populations
mais il est vrai que chef de l'état
estime que des élus de proximité il y en
a trop bien trop alors il est en train
de concocter sous les lambris dorés de
l'elysée
un vrai coup d'état pour fissurer les
territoires et supprimer écoutez bien
cent mille conseillers municipaux plus
de 20% des élus départementaux et
régionaux devraient fusionner et bien
ne laissons pas faire ne laissons pas
démanteler la protection sociale et les
retraites augmenter le forfait
hospitalier l'humanité l'a dit cette
semaine
nous ne voulons pas passer de la carte
vitale à la carte bleue de l'argent pour
la santé et les retraites
on peut en trouver que les revenus de la
finance cotisent au niveau des salaires
que l'industrie pharmaceutique apporte
sa contribution que cesse des
allégements de cotisations consentis aux
grandes entreprises qu'elles payent tous
leurs dettes qu'elles doivent à la
sécurité sociale
et tout le monde se portera bien mieux
monsieur le président nous ne vous
lâcherons pas nous allons vous empêcher
de privatiser la poste
il y aura la grève du 22 septembre puis
nous allons assurer un grand succès au
référendum pour la poste le 3 octobre
prochain
ne croyez pas ne croyez pas que le
peuple va se laisser faire face à ces
injustices criant à ce massacre social
que vous organisez le 7 octobre les
salariés se mobiliseront pour les
salaires et l'emploi avec leurs
syndicats
quinze jours plus tard le 17e temps les
droits des femmes seront dans la rue
avec en particulier le combat contre les
graves menaces qui pèsent sur leurs
droits spécifiques à la retraite
quant à l'enseignement on y recherche
aujourd'hui les formes d'action les plus
larges rassembleuse pour mettre en échec
les suppressions d'emplois et les
régressions programme et nous ne vous
laisserons pas faire nous ne vous
laisserons pas détruire à petit feu les
paysans et les pêcheurs de ce pays
le 7 octobre le 5 octobre prochain au
niveau mondial et européen
on agira pour que le social prenne le
dessus sur le très libéral
il ne saurait être question bien au
contraire de renier les engagements pris
dans la campagne des élections
européennes ce qui est à l'ordre du jour
c'est de mobiliser sur tout le continent
pour conquérir de nouveaux droits et
ainsi réconcilier les peuples avec une
golf
européen qui jusque là les attendait sur
et je peux vous dire que les députés du
front de gauche que tous les députés de
la gauche unie européenne commenceront
mercredi prochain par voter contre la
reconduction de cet ultralibéral part au
zoo à la présidence de la commission
européenne
chers amis chers camarades restés
fidèles à l'oeuvre de jean jaurès
c est aussi et peut être surtout oeuvré
sans relâche au rassemblement du monde
du travail et de la culture au
rassemblement des forces sociales et des
forces politiques de gauche et
écologistes
ce n'est pas au moment où sarkozy élargi
sa majorité sur sa droite avec le
sinistre vicomte de villiers et sur sa
gauche qu'il faut diviser son propre
camp en lorgnant sur une partie de la
droite
rebaptisé paraît-il centre la pluralité
de la gauche devient une richesse quand
elle vise à mieux prendre en compte des
aspirations populaires
mais elle est un obstacle quand elle est
la mine notre pays a besoin de
confrontations honnête sur les réponses
les plus efficaces à apporter aux
difficultés que rencontre toute la
population elle a besoin que ces
confrontations bénéficie de l'apport des
premiers intéressés
toutes les femmes les hommes les jeunes
les organisations sociales qui veulent
donner durablement un sens progressiste
à la vie du plus grand nombre et au
devenir de la planète
c'est ce qu'a indiqué à nouveau hier
avec force
mon amie marie george buffet en
proposant de lancer dès demain
un grand débat d'idées à gauche la
gauche en effet besoin d'innovation
politique qui roulent avec des pratiques
et des conceptions dont bien des
citoyens ne veulent plus telle est
l'ambition du front de gauche et de ces
trois composants la gauche unitaire
le parti communiste français et le parti
de gauche qui s'est créée pour les
élections européennes mais mais voyons
bien que nous ne sommes encore qu'au
tout début
très loin du conte mesures ont bien
lucidement l'ampleur la qualité des
efforts à accomplir pour que le
rassemblement qui est en train de naître
devienne populaire mais surtout
majoritaire
et le front de gauche et le front de
gauche n'a pas vocation à combattre une
partie de la gauche il a vocation à
permettre de la défaite de la droite en
ressources sur le gauche en ressources
en la gauche toute la gauche à des
voleurs des objectifs et des pratiques
de nature à toujours faire fait valoir
les dimensions humaines l'intérêt
général et celui de notre planète terre
voilà la question pour les prochaines
élections régionales dont on parle tant
il s'agira d'empêcher la droite de faire
main basse sur les régions de l'empêcher
d'avoir les coudées encore plus franches
dans la mise en oeuvre de sa politique
nationale qui fait déjà tant de dégâts
de l'empêcher aussi deux détruit les
collectivités locales dont elles
estiment qu'elles défendent trop les
populations contre ces mauvais goût et
aussi d'empêcher enfin d'ouvrir un
boulevard à la réélection de sarkozy en
les électrices et les électeurs ne se
mobiliseront pas spontanément beaucoup
dépendra de nous beaucoup dépendra de la
qualité de la crédibilité
et de la nouveauté de ce que la gauche
dans sa diversité proposera pour
résoudre les difficultés et étend la
démocratie de ce qu'elle fera pour que
dans tous les cas de figure en prenant
compte des spécificités de chaque région
le rassemblement le plus large le plus
au lit le plus convaincant pour que
s'opère un rassemblement de la gauche et
des écologistes
et c'est pour cela que les ateliers
proposés par marie george buffet sont
très importants participer si on peut
compter on peut compter sur nous pour
impulser une telle dynamique novatrice
chers amis chers camarades
c'est dans cet esprit combatif cet
esprit de réflexion d'élaboration des
changes qui anime les équipes de
l'humanité et de l'humanité dimanche
c'est cet esprit qui nous conduit à
préparer une nouvelle humanité qui
sortira le 13 octobre prochain avec
l'espoir d'être avec l'espoir qu'il soit
encore mieux encore votre journal car le
journal fondé par jean jaurès garde
chevillée au corps et au coeur
l'espoir d'un monde meilleur oui nous
n'avons que ce souci faire vivre avec
vous une nouvelle espérance et c'est
possible oui nous faisons nôtre sefra de
saint-just le bonheur est toujours une
idée neuve alors
alors eh bien me annie debout debout
construisons ensemble ce bonheur
e
oh
c'était son rôle
à
mais passer son temps
tous les soirs
le monde
je ne veux pas
salut
a bordeaux